[Music]
cheer
[Music]
as much fun as it is to come to a bar
lately here in tokyo now that coveted
restrictions have lifted we're facing
yet another problem the weekend
stoma kobayashi imports german beers
that get served at stores across japan
including this one
[Music]
says he's been losing sleep over the
uncertainty with the weak yen adding
even more stress than before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
other businesses also feel the pain of
trying to survive the latest hurdle
without losing customers as the yen hit
its weakest level in 20 years
[Music]
with a food self-sufficiency rate of 37
percent japan is highly dependent on
food imports such as beef
[Music]
okay
and even seafood
japan has been importing salmon from
norway often sold at supermarkets and
used in restaurants for sushi and other
dishes
[Music]
for now even drinking your sorrows away
could cost you a pretty yen
thanks so much for watching for more
videos like this you can train bloomberg
quick take for free 24 7 in any of the
places below get live news coverage
interviews deep dives shows and
documentaries on the stories you care
about most and be sure to follow or
subscribe to us on twitter youtube
instagram and facebook